Nous sommes à Saint-Maximin dans l'Oise,
à six mètres sous terre.
Ici se trouvent des galeries gigantesques
que connaît par cœur Denis Montagne.
Son métier,
inspecteur de carrières souterraines.
Vous voyez le décollement, là ?
Il y a une fracturation naturelle,
la grande, là,
c'est la pierre tombale assurée
si vous passez le mauvais jour.
Aujourd'hui sous surveillance,
ces carrières sont une chance incroyable pour
les ouvriers de Chantilly à la Renaissance.
Elles sont situées seulement
à 7 kilomètres du chantier.
Grosso modo depuis 2000 ans,
vous avez une activité extractive.
On a la chance d'avoir un des
plus grands sites carriers de France,
avec une pierre de qualité et qui
a fourni pour toutes les époques.
Donc, il a servi toute
la construction de Paris,
construction de Versailles,
tous les grands châteaux.
Si ces carrières sont si prisées,
c'est qu'elles abritent une pierre
d'une qualité exceptionnelle.
C'est une pierre homogène, de qualité,
qui est belle, qui est réputée,
elle se taille bien.
Vous la rayez à l'ongle, elle se travaille
bien à l'outil, elle a tout pour plaire.
Une pierre assez blonde qui joue
bien avec le soleil de Picardie.
Et puis c'est une pierre qui permet en effet
des sculptures de très bonne qualité.
Mais avant de sculpter la pierre,
il faut l'extraire.
À la Renaissance, les ouvriers de Chantilly
n'avaient qu'un outil à leur disposition,
une sorte de piolet très rudimentaire.
Vous allez enlever de la pierre
de manière régulière,
sous toute la surface
que vous voulez extraire.
Les tailleurs de pierre répètent alors
l'opération de chaque côté du bloc.
Et à ce moment-là, le bloc va se détacher.
C'est un travail éreintant.
Donc vous avez un rendement pour quelqu'un
qui travaille une dizaine d'heures par jour,
d'un mètre cube par semaine.
Sachant que le bâtiment à construire
fait 60 mètres par 30 mètres,
le chantier du Petit Château
prend beaucoup de temps.
Trop au goût du commanditaire.
Ils sont toujours sous la pression
de finir les travaux au bon moment,
parce que le connétable
et la cour vont venir.
Et parfois, ils sont obligés de travailler
très vite et peut-être trop vite,
pour pouvoir avancer dans les temps.
Et on voit qu'une partie de la fondation
du Petit Château n'est pas très bien faite,
avec des matériaux de récupération
qu'on a mis très vite en œuvre.
Ça, il est probable que c'est
une contrainte pas du tout technique,
mais c'est une contrainte liée à un mécène
qui trouve que ça ne va pas assez vite.
Ce qui aura pour conséquence un affaissement
du plancher de huit centimètres,
cinq siècles plus tard.
Toujours est-il qu'à l'époque,
tout semble tenir.
Le nouveau bâtiment est terminé
en seulement six ans,
et respecte parfaitement
les exigences du commanditaire.
Une structure rectangulaire
à la géométrie parfaite,
une superficie supplémentaire de 2000 m²,
le tout orné de centaines de sculptures.
C'est l'élégance, la maîtrise, la rigueur.
Une répartition quand même
très mesurée de l'ornement.
Une vraie leçon
de maîtrise de la géométrie.
Chantilly est prêt à recevoir et à éblouir
les plus grands rois d'Europe.